bulbasaur charmander squirtle it doesn't
matter who you'd pick as your starting
pokemon it looks like Hollywood's just
gotta catch em all I'm Simon and this is
your pokey battle news update The
Hollywood Reporter has detailed that the
film rights for the Pokemon franchise
are allegedly close to being purchased
by legendary entertainment according to
the report the company is attempting to
nudge aside warner brothers who has been
aggressively pursuing the rights to the
pokemon movies the rights to the Pokemon
franchise are managed by a Japanese
company the pokemon company who
according to the report has been
pitching for Hollywood to produce a
big-budget live-action take on the
intellectual property if legendary were
to acquire the rights there could be
political problems given the current
state of Chinese Japanese political
tensions Warner Brothers released
pokemon the first movie in 1999 to
commercial success and followed with
pokemon the movie 2000 and then Pokemon
3 the movie in 2001 which Pokemon would
you like to see battle it out in a live
action movie let us know in the comments
below we'll come find me on Twitter i'm
at the j cannell thanks for watching and
for all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot's
you